this is Toby cathwell historian author
and expert on medieval and Renaissance
arms and armor today he's joining us to
break down the armor from a selection of
games both historical and Fantastical
look at this armor he's got gaps all
over the place you know with a totally
unprotected neck and head open arms
sides of the chest exposed it should be
really easy to kill this guy we've got
more videos with Toby plans so make sure
to stay tuned and let us know in the
comments what games or armor sets you'd
like to see on the show be they
realistic fantasy sci-fi or Beyond and
of course other experts will be making
future appearances too of course mate
I've done that so many times that's just
so realistic not
right over to Toby
[Music]
this is a little clunky looking but it's
basically giving you a vague outline a
vague and pre impression of some kind of
generic medieval night the helmet that
he's wearing it's a it's an okay
rendition of a sort of 13th century
Western European Helm but it's too small
in proportion to his head and the body
one of the most Central principles of
armored design is the principle of
layering that you don't just have one
defense you take different materials
with different protective properties and
you combine them together so a Helm like
this is actually the the outermost layer
of a whole system where you have
internal layers of padded textile mail
and even a smaller helmet worn
underneath so in reality this Helm
shouldn't be so skin tight it should be
a bit bigger on his head and and I'm not
I have no idea what's going on with his
around his throat he's got these this
weird kind of
row of oblong plates going around I mean
what is that there's there's no sort of
recognizable precedent for what what
they think they're doing here the the
heraldry is okay it's kind of nice to
see that the sun in splendor is a real
heraldic image although this one's a bit
cartoony and a bit kind of Monty Python
so it kind of clashes with the rest of
the image it's kind of weird looking but
you know it has some kind of medieval
ancestor all right
so this guy's armor is supposed to be
made out of stone however impressive
that might seem stone or rock of any
sort is not really an appropriate
material for armor it's super super
brittle if you hit this stuff no matter
how thick and heavy it is it's just
going to shatter there is one example I
can think of of stone armor that was
made for a for funery use burial use in
China but that's not even meant to be
worn by anybody that's just like a you
know like a set dressing or you know a
funeral costume this guy is carrying way
more weight than he needs to he's got
all of these big plates sticking out and
extending down way more than they should
and so he has a problem with weight
efficiency again if we're treating this
as a real practical thing with plate
armor you need to carry as much metal as
you need to keep your body safe but no
more metal than is absolutely necessary
you have to justify every 200 grams that
you put on your body and if it doesn't
need to be there you get rid of it and I
don't care how cool it you might think
it looks it shouldn't be there if it's
if it's inefficient
there's something weird with this armor
he's got this leather and mail thing
where they want it to be plate armor to
look like rigid plates but they also
want the male and instead of figuring
out how that should work they've made
semi-rigid leather plates and then put
mail on them and that's kind of missing
the point of all of this this is armor
that won't be any good as played and
won't be any good as male because it's
not allowing those two materials to do
what they're good at you know plates are
rigid and smooth they deflect things
they stop points they glance you cover a
plate in mail like that you're just a
lot you're just losing all of that
protective property and the thing about
mail is they could be really closely
fitted to the body it's like metal
Fabric and you want it to be close
fitting because it's it's just to stop
laceration you know the plate will do
that anyway that's not what this is for
this is again purely about Aesthetics
and whoever's designed this isn't
equipped to be thinking about function
his opponents have a lot there's a lot
more real medieval stuff going on there
with like um chains sewn to the sleeves
of coats and things and they're all
wearing helmets you know why do the why
do the bad guys get to wear helmets but
our hero isn't wearing a helmet that
seems like an oversight on his part oh
he's got an upgrade the designers have
looked at late 15th century armor
specifically German Gothic armor of the
1480s and 90s there's some kind of
reference going on here but there are
some major problems too again first of
all doesn't matter how
impressive his full plate armor on his
body is if he's not got a helmet you
might as well not wear the rest of it if
you haven't got a helmet and also I
think they're they've rushed into the
design of the exterior layer without
thinking enough about what's supposed to
be going on underneath so this is an
arming doublet
you know this is what you wear under
full plate armor like this the armor
will not work unless it's got the right
undergarments underneath and uh I mean
although they seem to be aware in the
design here that he's got some kind of
fancy textile garment underneath it's
not doing its job this isn't just a
fancy thing to wear underneath an arming
doublet has arming points on it it's a
foundation garment it's got the
attachment points for the armor
integrated into it you attach the leg
armor to it you attach the shoulders the
arms everything runs off a doublet like
this and we on this armor we should see
those attachment points you know again
the the lack of the kind of mechanical
authenticity is shown by the how his
shoulders are just kind of falling off
of his body there generally with a
shoulder defense like this I mean what
he's effectively doing here is he's
wearing the armor with the shoulder
undone whoever's put him in this armor
didn't know what they were doing you
know that should be down protecting your
whole shoulder right up uh you know
across to your to your neck and it's
it's going to have a lace right there
which is tying it down to the arming
doublet so you know it's actually
protecting you look at this armor he's
got gaps all over the place with a
totally unprotected neck and head open
arms sides of the chest exposed it
should be really easy to kill this guy
it just kind of degrades the character a
character like that should know how to
wear armor and should probably be
acquainted with the virtues of wearing
helmet neck protection things like that
ah okay Romans now I mean that's an
interesting point about design straight
away as soon as you look at a character
you know what your frame of reference is
this guy says Roman immediately so this
I think this is kind of interesting
because it's a fantasy no actual Roman
ever looked like this but it retains the
sense of Roman I mean just about anybody
can recognize this as Roman and what's
going on here is kind of interesting
because they are using real Roman
elements there's reference to a lot of
real stuff here but they're combining it
in a very improbable and fantasy way the
Romans had real mask helmets especially
in like the first and second centuries
A.D but the mask helmets were generally
worn for a kind of Cavalry game kind of
Javelin game it's almost like a
tournament where a Cavalry would Gallop
around and throw javelins at each other
and there was a lot of fancy costume and
stuff they wouldn't wear on the
battlefield and that's the context of
these Rome of these mask helmets the the
crests are you know typical of course in
the Roman period for marking out
officers and commanders the muscled
breastplate is more of a ancient Greek
thing that really predates the Romans
the Romans had them too Roman officers
sometimes wore muscled curasas of bronze
so that's a Roman element the the
pendant to rouges as they're called
these strips that hang down from the
waist you know that's more or less a
real Roman thing but the you know the
muscle curasses in the Roman period are
an older thing the mask helmets are a
newer thing so they're just taking
things that they like and mashing them
together to create a fantasy but that's
the kind of fantasy I like I would
rather the fantasy is based on something
and someone's cracked a book and done
some homework to develop the fantasy
rather than just making stuff up off the
top of your head it's now our Roman Hero
has encountered somebody who looks a
little more
sort of vaguely medieval
I guess we're allowed to
combine the mixed periods and characters
in this game
generally I really like seeing that a a
well-armored character is able to move
vigorously and fight well I mean that's
a nice thing to be able to see just
because he's covered head to foot in
metal doesn't mean that he has to be
lumbering and slow good metal armor
doesn't have to be that that thick to
give good protection and the vigorous
movement just you know combined with the
armor is nice to see so you can do a lot
more in armor than a lot of people think
you can one thing you can't do though as
as shown pretty categorically here is
swim and play armor whatever the
opposite of a life preserver is it must
be armor with that much metal on your
body just as as shown here if you go in
the water you're not coming back up
again
foreign
this looks a lot more like actual armor
I mean someone has clearly done a fair
amount of work to you know engage with
real armor understand it how is it put
together how do you wear it and what
does it look like when it's all put
together so I I suspect the designers
here have been looking at real stuff but
they've also been looking at reenactment
like the the knee plates are kind of
oversized and and some of the ways it's
put together is a a weensy bit clunky
the vision slits and the visor are too
wide but I'm I'm starting to really
nitpick now because overall this is the
best thing we've seen so far the martial
arts form of these guys is really good
too actually I know I'm not supposed to
be talking about that but the way
they're moving has bearing on what
equipment they're using as well and
we're getting a sense immediately that
the armor that they're wearing is
actually doing something he got cut
there and that heard him but he'd gotten
hit a few other times earlier where the
reactions were less severe so they're
thinking actually about armor as a
practical thing that will benefit the
character not just the Cosmetic Skin you
get a really nice sense in this and how
the armor is a major obstacle and that
you have to somehow get past the
defenses that your opponent's wearing
and it's laborious and difficult and a
lot of the things that you try fail
all right
oh bows okay this is good long bows
against armor is like one of the
all-time most misconceived aspects of
medieval combat well but I mean again
you're seeing what the armor does you
know the strongest parts of the armor
will stop arrows perfectly well and
hurting someone as well armored as this
depends on luck that Lucky Strike or
just the cumulative effect of lots of of
small wounds starting to add up the
different kinds of reactions here that
the reactions are geared to where he
gets hit how many times he's been hit
it's easy and very common to over
accentuate the blunt trauma aspect of
War arrows these things are not carrying
a lot of inertia they don't there's
really no such thing as significant
blunt trauma when you're getting hit by
arrows but you know he ultimately got
killed by a lucky shot through the site
which is totally plausible I mean that
is by a very long way
the the best thing we've seen so far and
I think it's probably going to stay the
best thing we're gonna see
so this is a fantasy game it's a
Japanese Fantasy game but it's it's
making a very specific historical
reference here which I really like
obviously the Japanese had their own
nightly culture the samurai they had
their own traditions of armored combat
their own armor technology that evolved
totally independently of anything that's
going on in Europe up until the arrival
of of Europeans in Japan by the 16th
century European plate armor was being
imported into Japan and the Japanese
took some interest in it there were some
pla some pieces they really liked as you
can see on our our giant armored guy
here
these are these helmets with these kind
of uh almond shaped skulls with the
little with the brim that's called a
Cabo set very typical you know European
helmet of the second half of the 16th
century and he's also wearing a deeply
pointed so-called kind of peas called
breastplate and those are two elements
that the Japanese were really taken with
and there's surviving Japanese armor
that incorporates those European
elements the Japanese actually had a
word for armor like this that
incorporated European pieces they called
it nanban armor or Barbarian armor
foreign or Barbarian same thing so that
particular helmet and this particular
type of breastplate and the overall kind
of 16th early 17th century look of this
character
is actually bang on for this very
specific armor context they never were
interested in big European swords and
they didn't really ever have a use for
the articulated arm and leg defenses
they've added that as the kind of
fantasy element but there's some core
reference here that that I I really
appreciate I mean plate armor gives you
really great protection especially
against Cuts I mean this guy can cut
with that sword all day long and he's
never gonna get anywhere with someone
wearing this kind of armor stabbing in
the gaps is what he should have been
doing more of all along I mean this is
true though you know fighting vigorously
in armor like that is tiring
and they seem to be taking that into
account in this game if the player can
just keep him fighting and let him Tire
himself out you'll have a better chance
and that's real in a real situation that
wouldn't be a bad idea because you can't
fight vigorously in 25 or 30 kilos of
armor for very long even if you're a
really fit trained Warrior you still
only got a couple of minutes of of
continuous action before you're going to
start slowing down and getting tired
okay here we go yeah I hate this already
yeah there's all kinds of
silliness
weird modern tropes happening here let's
start with the most obvious thing these
the horns on the helmet there are some
historical examples very few but there
are some historical examples of horned
helmets but in all cases there's some
ancient Greek ones there's some Celtic
ones they're always purely ceremonial
they're costumes for some kind of
spectacle or festival or ceremony they
never intend to fight in horned helmets
the Japanese have them occasionally but
they're usually really lightly built and
expected to get destroyed in the first
contact with the Enemy Japanese writers
actually said it's a glorious sight to
see the crests of helmets destroyed in
the first action of a battle or whatever
but you know pseudo fantasy Viking guys
like this swaggering around with horned
helmets is just it's just silly I mean
as a general rule as a martial artist
it's a general rule that if you get
control of your opponent's head
you win or at least you have a serious
Advantage so why are you putting handles
on your head you're doing an enormous
service to anybody who comes to grips
with you and you know this whole
downturn thing uh people think it looks
butch or whatever it's stupid stop it so
I presume at some point he gets an armor
upgrade or something yeah
this is an armor upgrade glass armor
I wouldn't have thought glass armor is a
good idea
it's really goofy looking
no I don't don't like it at all I'm
sorry it's goofy looking
just a couple of quick comments on our
heroines get up here there's a couple of
pretty common modern misconceptions that
are encapsulated in this character the
most basic one is leather clothes I mean
throughout history people of whatever
culture certainly in Europe almost never
made clothes out of leather and yet it's
somehow this modern idea
that people in the in history wore biker
gear it happens in film television games
all over the place I don't know where it
came from why people think that looks
medieval but it doesn't the other kind
of weird thing about this character's
look is that she's only wearing one
piece of plate armor and that's fine but
one elbow to the exclusion of anything
else but generally when you wear armor
it's because you have some kind of
priority if you've got one piece of
plate armor you put it somewhere that
really matters and one elbow doesn't
really get her anything and she's a
Slinger so she's actually and starting
to encumber a bit her her slinging arm
it doesn't make a lot of sense and
certainly doesn't excuse whatever
protective benefit she might be getting
out of this
I like the idea of an imposing heavily
armored opponent facing off against
someone who's only got a sling that's a
kind of an interesting problem of weapon
versus Armor but this individual's armor
it's just kind of weird and not obeying
the laws of gravity and not actually
designed particularly well I mean look
at the leg armor for example this is not
how you build leg armor he's got these
random individual plates just kind of
magically stuck to places where they
should just slip down a strap around the
back of the leg is not going to hold
these pieces up good leg armor has to be
an integrated assembly of pieces riveted
together and then tied up at the hip to
support it and this is kind of
Mandalorian style fantasy leg armor that
quite apart from the physics of it look
at the gaps I mean what is the point in
even wearing this when you can stab him
just about anywhere you like and chances
are you'll hurt him also look at that
look at his his breastplate doesn't have
really any shape at all and it the
breastplate is actually overlapping the
show older plates which is exactly the
reverse of what you want things that are
moving have to be overlapping the things
that aren't moving and also look at this
his whole neck and throat are exposed
the neck and throat is one of the most
dangerous most vulnerable areas of the
human body so he's paying a huge price
in in in the physical weight and and the
cost and encumbrance of wearing big
plates like this I mean none of this
armor is actually doing very much and
and in the game play it seems like you
have to hit him with the sling and knock
the pieces of armor off before you can
hurt him but you know she would have no
problem hurting this person and she
doesn't need to make any of the plates
disappear to do it
1415 northern France
the Hundred Years War continues so they
are really closely defining the context
here this isn't some fantasy thing often
some you know vague period in some other
history this is 1415 in France Battle of
Agincourt but when you're defining the
historical context this specifically
then you've got a whole new pressure on
your historical authenticity and in the
quality of the design and this is
already just all over the place they've
blown it before they've even started
what we're seeing here is a is a mixture
of 13th 14th 15th 16th century elements
all mashed together the shape of the
banners and the the heraldry is off and
just this idea of one Army all wearing
red and the other Army all wearing blue
this is like the Middle Ages according
to Playmobil and actually I think this
might be an instance where the perceived
requirements of the game and the game
play are kind of interfering with their
ability to create a good visual image
like they've made certain assumptions
about how the game needs to be played
well people aren't going to be able to
tell what side is what I would like to
see historical authenticity given more
of a chance before you Chuck it out the
window because you think it won't work
for your game
right here he is in his eye in his armor
okay
uh I mean what are you gonna what are
you gonna say about that this is its own
aesthetic it's moving way pretty far out
into the realm of something that doesn't
have anything to do with our universe
really climbing in armor you can
actually do more of that than you might
think there's a lot a lot of great
depictions of knights climbing Siege
ladders and full plate armor scaling
walls you need to be able to do that so
even in this Fantasy Realm that's a nice
thing to see this is a little bit more
vaguely
historical sort of looking I like the
tail on the helmet there he's wearing a
salad with a tail at the back yeah
tailed helmets are really good for keep
you know protecting the back of your
neck from things falling on you and
stuff like that you can see how it's
protecting the back of his neck that's
why firefighters wear helmets like that
it's very similar kind of design profile
yeah we're starting to move well beyond
my authority to comment I think here
thank you so much for watching Remember
to comment below what other games you'd
like to see on the show and of course be
sure to subscribe for more content like
this and Beyond